les lois québécoises et ce qu'elle
facilite la vie des propriétaires de
condos qui rêvent d'une voiture
électrique
[Musique]
savez-vous qu'à vancouver il ya un
règlement municipal très clair depuis
20% des espaces de stationnement dans
une nouvelle tôt à condos doivent être
équipés pour pouvoir accueillir une
borne de recharge dès l'an prochain
c'est 100% des stationnements dans des
nouvelles tours à condos qui devront
avoir les infrastructures électriques
adéquat au québec il ya un projet de
réglementation qui est sur la table
depuis l'automne dernier
mais six mois plus tard le gouvernement
ne l'a toujours pas adopté ceci dit vous
pouvez faire installer une borne de
recharge électrique dans une tour à
condos existantes mais ça peut devenir
une course à obstacles votre place de
stationnement vous êtes le seul à
pouvoir l'utiliser mais dans une tour à
condos l'espace de stationnement est
souvent considérée comme un espace
commun et au québec
la réglementation exige que pour
modifier un espace commun il faut la
double majorité au syndicat de
copropriété et c'est vraiment là que ça
devient compliqué d'abord vous devez
avoir l'appui de 50 pour cent plus un
des copropriétaires mais en plus la
majorité qui vous appuyez doit détenir
au moins 75% de la valeur de l'immeuble
pour simplifier les choses
les règles ontarienne n'exige qu'une
majorité simple pour faire installer une
borne de recharge dans une tour à condos
la subvention maintenant québec offrait
remboursement qui parlait jusqu'à 600
dollars pour faire installer une borne
de recharge
mais comme on le disait un stationnement
dans une tour au cordeau c'est souvent
un espace commun et si par malheur
l'électricien qui installe la borne fait
la facture au nom du syndicat de
copropriété et bien vous n'avez pas le
droit au remboursement il faut
absolument que l'électricien fasses ta
facture à votre nom pour être robe
alors qu'en colombie britannique la
subvention est beaucoup mieux adapté à
la réalité de la copropriété